cette affaire est étonnante parce que il
semble que la franchissement de la
frontière le 7 octobre et dépasser les
espérances les plus folles de ceux qui
l'avaient misise en œuvre à tel point
que maintenant il y a 3000 personnes qui
ont qui ont traversé et les 3000
nétaient pas tous le hamass c'est-à-dire
que quand ça a été ouvert les
prontaliers se sont rué derrière selon
un peu un mode qui est celui de la radia
il faut bien voir que c'est quelque
chose qui très présent dans l'imaginaire
religieux musulman et ça c'est une radia
d'une certaine manière c'est on arrive
on prend on tue le plus de gens possible
dans le passé on prenait les femmes pour
les mettre dans les harem et on les
enfants pour en faire des musulmans là
c'est pour en faire des otages pas
seulement les femmes mais tous les gens
qui étaient disponibles d'une manière
assez irrationnelle qui fait que d'une
certaine façon aujourd'hui la masse des
otages à gérer est un problème pour ceux
qui les détiennent et ça pose aussi un
très gros problème au CAT
qui a été érigé ou s'est érigé en
intermédiaire parce que d'une certaine
manière il a la corresponsabilité de la
sûreté des otages ce qui pour les otages
est une forme d'assurance mais dans
la en fonction des aléas des
bombardements et aujourd'hui donc
personne ne pas dire grandchose ça ça
donne le sentiment que l'opération a en
tout cas une fois la frontière franchie
échappé à ses concepteurs quels qu'il
soi alors quels sont les concepteurs euh
il me semble euh impensable que moi j'ai
traversé cette frontière je sais pas 5
six fois à peu près et déjà il y a un
certain temps avec les champs labourés
des senseurs
partout des des miradors électroniques
il me semble impossible que le garagiste
du Hamas avec sa sa pince et sa clé à
molette ait pu désactiver tout ça il y a
eu 29 passages euh donc c'est quand même
c'est quelque chose de gigantesque il y
a eu des actions
coordonné aérienne
maritime enfin c'était ça n'est pas
possible ça ce qui a surpris
l'establishment iranien
et du Hezbollah c'est le le jour du
déclenchement mainant ditons en revanche
la
préparation il a été attesté que ça fait
15 à 16 mois que aussi bien au Liban que
dans les zones chiites d'Irak les des
exercices des drills j'ai ça en anglais
de préparation avait été effectué parce
qu' il est impensable que cette
coordination ait été décidée par un type
de toi tu vas là toi tu vas ici donc ça
c'est tout à fait euh à écarter